foreign nine days after arriving in Doha
from Maryland in the U.S football fan
David Canal was in a quad bike accident
he fractured 12 ribs and damaged his
lungs
after he was discharged from hospital
Qatari authorities moved him and his
family to this five-bedroom Villa at a
Recovery Center opened especially for
the World Cup we have food breakfast
lunch and dinner Transportation where we
want to we have service who helps us out
here in the house with everything we
need and anything we need we just asked
for and they're happy to to provide
anything for us so since we arrived here
we haven't had to spend anything
the family have been given a bicycle and
an iPad for nine-year-old Aika as well
as cable television to watch the matches
a doctor and a nurse visit David every
day to dress his wounds and prescribe
pain medication this Recovery Center
where David Irina and Ikea have been
staying for the past 12 days has a total
of 19 Villas a swimming pool and a gym
families can stay here for free for as
long as they need to recover
the family said they chose to speak out
because they're grateful for the
assistance they've received we feel a
little bit like celebrities because I
mean you don't see this kind of help on
the U.S
and I mean we're really glad that she
was able to be in contact with with the
ministry and in everything that they did
for us as right now as being more than
enough
the families say they plan to stay in
Doha until the end of the tournament to
enjoy the last few days of what the
World Cup has to offer
Victoria Gayton B Al Jazeera Doha